so um that's the situation or that's the
pair of situations we're going to use
the pair of models we're going to use to
unpack these different questions so
let's have a look
at this example here and this by the way
as an example we're going to do in two
halves so we're going to have a go at it
together
and then i'm going to set you a sort of
secondary question that's going to take
you
um that you're going to do independently
and we'll come back together
so um read it with me and you have to
write all down let's just capture the
important information as we go
a particle is projected upwards in a
medium
for which the resistance to the motion
is one-fifth of the mass
times the velocity okay that absolutely
needs to be highlighted so let's just
have a look at that
uh this is the resistance that's being
described here right it's one-fifth of
the mass
times the velocity so you can see
right here this one-fifth
this is the k that we're talking about
right so this is the constant of
proportionality i guess you could name
it if you wanted to
one-fifth of the mass so there's
one-fifth times
m and then it's multiplied by the
velocity i did say before
sometimes you'll multiply by the
velocity squared uh in theory there's
nothing wrong with being multiplied by
velocity cubed or to the power of four
but in the context of the course you'll
really only see velocity of velocity
squared
so i'm just going to underline that
that's equally important
so this is um
sorry m and then k and then v and it's
it's resistance so it's a minus sign
that that's implied uh opposite in
direction i guess we could highlight
that as well
but you don't really need to say that
when it's resistance okay
uh let's keep going the initial velocity
is 30 meters per second
there you go that's important to work
out we're going to have to
integrate and we'll use that to solve
for our constant of integration
let y be its height in meters above the
point of projection
after t seconds so t equals 0 is our
initial condition uh and y will be
uh zero when it's projected upwards in a
medium you start from the bottom
um above the point of projection after
all uh we're setting gravity to be ten
and then they provide to us very nicely
how polite of them
they actually in this case and it makes
sense because this is an initial example
they give us the acceleration equation
this is what it should be right
um you may like to put just beside this
right where did they get this from well
if we were to write the forces
you're going to get with this is the
upwards journey so just going back to
that table before
this is this situation here isn't it so
we've got
um g being set as 10 and
the mass is is not um defined but we
don't need the mass
because if i say minus 10
m there's the um minus mg and then
minus a fifth there's the
k times m v you can see all i need to do
to get from this force equation
to this acceleration equation
is i'm dividing through by m as
according to f equals m a
all right so we've set ourselves up uh
and you know they've given us this
equation we can work with it now what
that question is well the first part of
the question is find y
as a function of the velocity v and
hence
find its maximum height so that's a bit
sneaky there's kind of like a second
part to this question but it's fairly
trivial
okay so how are we going to begin well
i'm going to start with this
acceleration equation y double dot
equals
this but i noticed that where i'm trying
to go to
is y as a function of v right
so if i've got acceleration here i'm
going to need to do some kind of
integration so as we've seen before
i need to choose a form for acceleration
that's going to be most helpful
to get me towards y as a function of v
right so if for example i wrote down
y double dot and i'm going to put this
together on as one fraction
so if i put say for example this is
going to be 50
on 5 plus v on 5 i'm trying to get my
common denominator here
which form is going to be most helpful
post it in the chat i'll give you a
second
just like we did on tuesday which form
of acceleration do you think will be
most useful
um to you know get us on the path to
integration okay charms in
early very good but with some question
marks um and i think
i know why you're like is that what it
is uh does anyone else want to weigh in
what do you guys
think okay we can uh have a go with the
yeah all right i'm
liking that we've got wires in here
because we've got vertical resisted
motion rather than horizontal
so you never think about this right
which is the best
candidate now you can go through any way
that you like
whether it's going to be the most
efficient part of you is another
question
um i'm going to throw in a vote for
charms and let's see what happens right
if i go
v dv on d y we are
used to writing v dv on dx but this is
vertical
motion what am i going to get well let's
have a look at the right hand side i've
got that minus sign there
and i got everything on the denominator
of five so i could combine this together
so i'm gonna get 50 plus v
that's all divided by five now why is
this helpful i want you to anticipate
where we're going to go
next i like this because i've got
y's appearing you can see this d y here
if i start to integrate that that will
give me a y equals something or other
and then i've also got everything else
is in terms of v's right there's a v
there's a dv there's another v over
there so
i've got the two pieces that i want
right i've got my
y i've got my v and after i integrate
i'm just going to need to
um find out my constant of integration
and then
you know do some algebraic manipulation
to make y the subject
so this is promising let's see what
happens when we
try and twist and turn this i'm going to
do my separation of variables step here
so i'm noticing that i've got let's
highlight it just up here
these v terms over on the right hand
side i want to divide through
by those so that gives me v on
50 plus v i'm happy to leave that dv
over there on the left hand side with
the v's where it belongs and i'm going
to multiply that dy
over to the other side so that gives you
minus 1 over
5 d y so this is promising
what do i do with this um i know how to
integrate the right hand side that's no
problem
and the left hand side that looks a
little more awkward so you're going to
think back
to some of your further integration
skills though honestly you don't need to
be an extension 2 student
to see how to manipulate this thing on
the left hand side
have a think it doesn't look like it's
like in an f dash on
f situation um but it wouldn't be hard
to modify it so that it was
right uh here's what i'm going to do on
the left hand side
i'm going to say if if i wanted to have
an f dash on f situation
right uh the f in this case is 50 plus v
so the f dash would be one in this case
so if i had one
on the top or any integer not integer
any constant uh multiple of one
a constant coefficient in front of the
one then i'd be good right it'd be an f
dash on f situation
so in order to do that i'm going to pull
a trick we've done before
dealing with integrals with
rational integrands i'm going to
manipulate this numerator in just a
teeny tiny way
um by putting a 50 up the top there you
can't just add 50 because you want to
you're gonna have to subtract 50 to keep
it all balanced and all of that is still
on the
same denominator 50 plus v
and then there's a dv over there now
hopefully
you're convinced that uh nothing has
changed on the left hand side
but this is better to work with right
because you can see here
that this 50 plus v on 50 plus v that
i can separate out as its own fraction
that'll just be one
and then you can say all right this uh
minus
50 on 50 plus v
that is the f dash on f situation that i
was looking for
just there's an extra factor of minus
50. so
this i can deal with let's have a go i'm
going to separate that
50 plus v on 50 plus v as one then i'm
going to say
minus 50 lots of and then i've got
one on 50 plus v
there and all of this
has a dv um attached to it i'm just
going to move i'm running out of space
over on the left hand side here it's
just sort of ballooning out so
let's actually move it over sorry i'm
cheating i know you can't do that
let's move that over so i have a bit
more room to breathe
okay and nothing has changed on the
right hand side so i'm just gonna
pop that down all right um at this point
i am ready to integrate so in fact i'm
so lazy that i don't even need to write
a whole new line that just has the
integral on both sides so i'll just
highlight that in different colors just
so you can see it's a whole different
step there
let's go ahead and let's integrate right
so i'm getting
v on the left hand side minus
50 log
of 50 plus
v equals uh what do i get on the right
hand side this is
minus 1 over 5
y plus my constant okay does that look
alright to you i need to find out what
this constant is
equal to so i'm just going to pause for
a minute and i'm going to let you
do the substitution according to if i
just zoom out so you can see
this situation here can you work out
what all of that is going
to be equal to if you work out what your
constant is
let me pause and once you get that into
your um
uh into your own question you can pop it
in the chat just let me
pause and see if you can catch up to me